the u.s republican party's only black
senator has been subjected to a torrent
of abuse online
after daring to say america is not a
racist country
tim scott was quick to respond to those
attacks
it is stunning in 2021 that those who
speak about
ending discrimination want to end it by
more discrimination
the left has doubled down that they are
going to not attack my policies
but they're literally attacking the
colour of my skin
tim scott allowed himself to be used as
a tool by people who are fighting to
maintain white supremacy
it's disheartening to see tim scott
doesn't speak for black folks
not when the vast majority of us don't
claim him
representative tim scott is just a
filled hand expressing appreciation for
being invited into the big house
it all started when senator scott gave a
rebuttal of joe biden's address to
congress accusing the president of
sowing division
democrats politicians then laid into the
senator accusing him of aiding and
abetting white supremacy
and the campaign started on twitter with
people branding scott uncle tim
a play on the anti-blank racial slur
uncle tom
for more than 12 hours the hashtag uncle
tim was trending on twitter before the
platform blocked it the social media
giants had to explain why that happened
derek gibson who's running for new york
state governor feels it twitter
interferes only when it benefits a
certain party
america is not a racist country yes we
have some racist people in the country
but we are not a racist country
if we were a racist country we wouldn't
have a country full of uh
immigrants coming over uh marching over
to get into this particular country so
uh for them to treat uh tim scott like
that was simply because he's a
republican
if that had a comment how that came from
a democrat would you uh
refer to cameron harris when she said
she agree with him
there will be absolutely no kickback on
it but just because the guys are black
republican uh they decided to use that
to try to smear the uh republican party
well the democrat
party uh they preach tolerance tolerance
solid but they're the most intolerant
people i've ever seen
i mean you can't wear certain shirts
certain caps or they want to destroy you
for so that is not tolerance
it's uh like i said once again it's very
hypocritical and they want to paint you
if you think for yourself
if you don't have the uh uh the hurt
sheep mentality and then they try to uh
cancel you from society but how dare a
black man speak out for himself